c'est quoi ton nom le boy et il
s'appelle le django freeman et vous
l'avez dégoter ou un événement fortuit
nous a réunis django et moi j'ai entendu
parler de toi que tu clame sur tous les
toits que c'est mandingue ne valent pas
un clou mme qu'il n'y a rien sur le
marché dash table alors là je suis
curieux de savoir ce qu'il fait tout un
si grand expert chez curieux de savoir
pourquoi vous êtes si curieux de savoir
qu'est ce que tu as dit le bronze se
calment match où il n'y avait pas de mal
alors je le prends pas mal
monsieur comme dit je vous serais
reconnaissant de vous adressez à moi
pour toute requête d'éclaircissements
tout d'abord mais vous n'avez pas de
verre puis je vous faire servir un goût
de rafraîchissement oui alors ils
viennent wonder var roscoe une bière
pour notre barbu baron est pour moi un
pêcheur de perles polynésienne et stoppa
chiche sur le rhum